hi there uh steve here again steve
kaufman to talk about language learning
[Music]
again i remind you
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe you can even uh
click on the little bell here to get
notifications and we certainly would be
happy to have you join us at link which
is where i learn languages
and of course here i like to talk about
learning languages
it's a little bit hazy outside today
because of the forest fires in the u.s
uh south of us we've had fewer forest
fires here in british columbia because
we had a lot of rain
uh in the late spring and early summer
so that our forests were wetter down
south there it's been a lot drier
and so they have these terrible forest
fires that have given vancouver one of
the worst
uh air qualities in the world apparently
if you believe
uh what you see on uh
you know on social media and tv and
elsewhere
but today i want to talk about passive
vocabulary
because i often hear this sort of like
at link for example we say a word is
known if you can recognize that word in
a context so if i'm working on link i
see a word i know what it means in the
context i can say i know that word i can
also say i don't know that word in other
words i decide if i know that word but
if i understand the word in that context
typically i will say i know it
it may be that in a subsequent context i
don't know what it means i may look it
up again i may move it back to you know
status three that i'm learning a word
that i'm learning rather than known but
i control that but the reason why i move
words to known
uh as soon as i can recognize them
i'm not so demanding of myself i i
realize that i know this word here i may
recognize it in a context but i probably
can't use it
i don't know it well enough to use it if
i have a conversation as i've had in
arabic with arabic tutors
i won't be able to produce that word but
it doesn't matter
passive vocabulary is key to developing
good comprehension
if i have good comprehension
and this of course is my goal in my
90-day challenge with arabic if i can
understand podcasts in arabic even if i
can't use all the words then i can turn
them on in the morning i'm listening to
a new podcast i'm understanding 80 of it
it's all washing over my brain
and in time as i gain more familiarity
with the language i will start to
activate some of those words but my
active vocabulary what i can use will
always be a smaller subset of the words
that i understand but in terms of
progressing in the language what's key
is comprehension and even if i have now
as i'm having conversations with my
arabic tutors i don't worry about what i
can't do by the way this is a t-shirt i
got we my old-timers hockey team played
against an old-timer's hockey team from
japan and they brought us this these
nice t-shirts
looks like the car the character for a
well like e in japanese or
you know
jing in chinese anyway as i was saying
so
uh when i speak with my tutors
it doesn't bother me when i fall down
i want to focus on understanding them
and all of that is helping my brain to
get used to the language and as i
struggle to find words
and then afterwards i remember the words
that i struggled to find i become more
attentive to those words when i see them
again in some context so
the i see these conversations as again
promoting better comprehension promoting
more attentiveness attentiveness to the
language
it's not where i want to perform and oh
i did well or i didn't do well because
inevitably
i'm going to do better sometimes than at
other times and i will gradually get
better at speaking but it won't be a
straight line
i might do well for a while and then i
might stumble it might be
my the vibes that this tutor gives me or
or whatever it might be a poor
connection on skype so the main thing
for me
is comprehension
and what that does to me is is it
reduces the level of of uh
apprehensiveness tension i'm not afraid
of my conversation i'm not going to
perform in front of my tutor it's just
an opportunity to engage with the
language and when we focus on
comprehension we're focusing on engaging
with the language and if i have
passive vocabulary then i can understand
more movies i can understand more
articles that i read i can understand
podcasts and all of that is sort of
building up my base as i start to speak
more i will slowly activate more but you
should definitely give yourself credit
for words that you understand in a
context and the idea that you're going
to somehow try to use that word in
different situations and only when you
use it can you claim that you know it
you're going to end up with such a
limited vocabulary you will never
achieve that broad base of comprehension
that you need in order to move forward
in the language so i i think i tweeted
out i said this emphasis that or the
suggestion that somehow passive
vocabulary is less important than that
active vocabulary is almost as damaging
as the idea that you can you know
master the basics of a language in the
early stages you can't you can only get
a better grasp
of you know correct usage once you have
enough
experience with the language once again
passive vocabulary and comprehension so
that's what i had to say
and i'll have a look and see how this
video turned out
[Music]